how you doing guys so something I try to
do on my channel if you're not familiar
with it is every once in a while I try
to find a film that I think is really
special that not a lot of people know
about and I call it an overlooked review
in the past I've done certain films I
have a playlist on my channel that you
can check out if you'd like to but today
we're going to be talking about a film
that came out in 1999 it's an anime film
called perfect blue was a pop star
who design to become an actress but
sometimes aspirations can be deadly
directed by Saito Shah icon hope I got
that right this gentleman has made quite
a bit of great enemies that you can look
into if you were interested in anime as
well he unfortunately has since passed
away but he is definitely one of the
best and most well known anime directors
possibly even second to higher Maya Zaki
perfect blue inhabits an extremely rare
genre in anime that of the psychological
thriller this is a genre that isn't that
well explored throughout anime and I
wish more anime directors would do it
because this film is honestly on a
Hitchcockian level of suspense in the
same time there are elements of Stanley
Kubrick in there as well that strange
off-kilter sense when you're watching a
movie you're not entirely sure what all
is real what's reality what's fantasy
perfect blue explores that beautifully
this film was about a young pop singer
named Mima and she decides that she
would rather be an actress because she's
tired of the pop world and when she does
this she continues to degrade herself by
allowing herself to do certain scenes
she would never think of doing before
other people are worried about her and
she starts to lose her grip on reality
at the same time strange murders are
taking place that seemed to relate to
her she's being stalked by an obsessive
fan and all this comes together and have
a really really intense animated film
believe it or not it's so cool to see a
film that's animated with such rich
drama intention and very famously the
film Black Swan by Darren Aronofsky has
been accused of copying off a perfect
blue and I got to say upon seeing
perfect blue and Black Swan there are
some serious striking similarities also
Aronofsky has purchased the rights to
perfect blue according to IMDB for fifty
nine thousand dollars just so he could
recreate the bathtub scene in perfect
blue in his film rec room for a dream
perhaps he felt that gave him more
leeway with Black Swan because they're
too strikingly similar films this film's
use of animation especially music and
great voice work lend to a really scary
film I'm not kidding this is actually
the scariest anime I've ever seen it
really got under my skin it is very
disturbing it's not for the
light-hearted trust me but if you like
anime like I do then I really think
you'll enjoy perfect blue it's
definitely the kind of movie that you
have to watch and really pay attention
you can't watch this movie and think
well I'm just going to enjoy perfect but
you really have to pay attention to like
each frame the director and the writers
of this movie really took such care and
telling a very very interesting
mystery story and I was enthralled by it
to be honest when perfect blue ended I
did something extremely rare that I
honestly basically never do I put it
right back in and I watched it again I
don't do that
I really don't do that I like to give
myself enough space to be able to kind
of saturate it and think about it I
wanted to revisit that movie immediately
and examine it and figure out what was
going on and try to get my own
interpretation of certain things because
this movie does have a bit of an open
interpretation kind of thing where you
can kind of put your own thoughts into
it but perfect blue is definitely a
movie for anime fans if you're
interested in psychological thrillers in
general I strongly suggest watching this
movie if you're interested in seeing a
film that really inspired Darren
Aronofsky I strongly suggest checking
this out as well perfect blue is one of
the best anime films I've ever seen I'm
gonna give it an A definitely check this
one out if you haven't if you're a fan
of anime for sure excuse me are you
serious five seconds hated sick a lot so
I will try to do more overlooked reviews
for you guys in the future and I hope
that you did enjoy this and as always
thanks a lot for watching and if you
like this you can click right here and
get stuck my next
Oh